hey everybody
movie retrospective time i have to say i
was not
uh all that surprised when this one won
the patreon poll
because i seriously can't believe we
haven't done
well [ __ ] it's not that we haven't done
day of the dead which is what we're
doing today the george romero movie
i don't think we've done dawn of the
dead did we do dawn of the dead i don't
think we did that one either or night of
the living dead guess it kind of took
him for granted
that's kind of what i was thinking and
it's like really the reason that i
decided i know it's kind of like ass
backwards that we're doing day of the
dead
first um but i guess i just thought of
it because i saw that it was on to be
when i was like scrolling through like
horror movies so i was like oh [ __ ] man
that's the one that i haven't seen like
i've saw that the longest time ago
so i wanted to kind of give it a revisit
uh so we uh watched it on toby last
night and today we're going to talk
about it
so uh yeah day of the dead this is
actually the least favorite of the
series for me
but yeah but watching it again it's real
watchable
it's real entertaining
it is yeah i liked it better than i
remembered liking it
me too yeah me too i mean it's been
several years
since i've seen it um you know obviously
george romero went on to make
you know other movies he made like land
of the dead he made a diary of the dead
um but a few couple other ones but it's
like this one is kind of like the third
of the first like unofficial
trilogy you know night of living dead in
1968 and then you had like dawn of the
dawn of the dead and then day of the day
came out in 1985
and so i kind of feel like i can see
where people are coming from
with i mean this still has like pretty
is really high ratings
on like uh you know rotten tomatoes and
all that other kind of stuff
but it's the lowest of the three and i
can see why
this is a really different um
it's different tonally yeah than dawn of
the dead for sure because i feel like
dawn of the dead was almost more
comedic a little bit yeah like it had
like a lot more comedy
sort of elements dawn of the dead had
some light-hearted move
moments in it yeah but it it it had a
lot of realism in it
it was yeah it had in the way of like
say like the walking dead
yeah it kind of has realism in it this
one is
in a way not as serious
even though a bunch of [ __ ] gore
happens in it
or it's not as realistic to me i had a
hard time with certain elements in the
movie but
it still does it was still fun to watch
yeah it just did that's how this is
going to come at you you can't take this
one totally seriously
well i feel like any horror movie that
came out in the 80s it's kind of hard
well especially because a lot of them
were like tonally kind of
um and this one in particular i can see
where people criticize it's like oh the
acting is over the top it's like
everyone's just kind of screaming at
each other the whole time
this is definitely i think the angriest
of the movies and also maybe the
bleakest
i think this is more similar tonally to
the original night of the living dead
which just like everybody's squabbling
and um and everything then than it is to
dawn of the dead so i think that
dawn of the dead is so revered and it's
like that's easily like the favorite of
everyone's you know out of those three
so i feel like people were expecting
another movie like that and george
romero
made a kind of a different a little bit
of a different take on it you know what
i'm saying yes it's open to
interpretation it is to me
there there were kind of elements of
[ __ ] the thing the original john
carter yeah with the isolation like
everyone yeah kind of at each other's
throats and [ __ ]
military outposts isolated an outside
threat
they don't trust each other there's
[ __ ] internal battles going on
it had that aspect to it totally i kind
of thought it was a little bit like
return of the living dead
but that's just me that's just mine see
i didn't get that at all i mean return
of the living dead was a straight up
comedy
i thought this was straight up comedy i
don't think it was meant to be
from the point of all right this is the
thing tom savini
is a [ __ ] vietnam veteran he he knows
military culture
all right there's a lot about the
soldiers in this movie that had me
laughing
because it's just not realistic so from
my point of view it was comedy
well like i said i could that's why a
lot of people like kind of accuse a lot
of the actors being like over the top
yeah it doesn't bother me as much
because i feel like
they don't really i don't think they
really specify in the timeline of the
movie how long
these people have been down there but it
seems like it's been a long time and
everyone's just kind of starting to lose
their [ __ ] minds
i mean not the military guys and the
scientists are all kind of starting to
crack
so i kind of feel like that might go a
long way toward explaining like why
everyone is acting like such a [ __ ]
lunatic
because they've been down there such a
long time there no progress is being
made they can't contact anybody else
they think they're the only people left
in the whole world and everyone's just
starting to like lose their [ __ ] yeah
it's just unclear
i mean look yeah you got a guy with a
really bad jamaican accent another guy
with a really bad irish accent you got
an
army of [ __ ] long-haired guys with
mix and match uniforms
from different periods the weapons were
for all from different periods
uh you got 50 something year old
privates serving underneath [ __ ]
40 year old captains you know it's just
it doesn't work that way yeah i mean how
if they had
somehow cleared up or cleaned up this
store to where
these aren't really soldiers these are
remnants of [ __ ] survivors from the
surface
that are just found old equipment and
became soldiers called themselves you
know
you don't know you don't know yeah
they're definitely not soldiers as i
knew them
and they're definitely not soldiers as
tom savini would have known him
he was in the infantry like me he was
just from another era
so he was vietnam he's a photographer
vietnam that's right he was with the
infantry yeah so you know it's kind of
like infantry service
so he knows how they really are you know
um and there's just no
not there's no military realism in it at
all
so from my point of view it was just
entertain entertainment and comment yeah
but like i said that's how i see it too
because it doesn't it doesn't really
bother me all that much and like i said
you know the scientists and they're kind
of like a little bit
over the top and caricatures also i just
and i just see it as how everyone's just
like losing their [ __ ] minds because
they've been underground
and there's zombies everywhere and they
don't know what to do about it or what's
going to happen and so
and they all hate each other so they're
all just kind of like losing their [ __ ]
for me being kind of like a [ __ ]
gun nut historical nut i'm tripping over
the weapons that they had
they look like cult spo sp ones or
spo1 [ __ ] rifles is what they look
like kind of like is an m16a1
the army version it has the forward
assist on it but not the brass deflector
with the old duckbill [ __ ]
flash suppressor on the end of it the
[ __ ] triangular hand guards it's
classic rifle today
but that would have been way out of date
even for the 80s you know that well see
that's the thing 60s i think in universe
i think this movie is not supposed to be
taking place in 1985 yeah i'm not sure
when it's supposed to be i think it's
only supposed to be
like in like in the um timeline of the
zombie apocalypse which like i said the
first movie which came out in 1968 and
then when dawn of the dead came out
would uh whenever that was what was that
1979 something like that
but i think there was only supposed to
be a couple of years in between those i
don't think it was supposed to be like
the amount of time between the movies
coming out yeah i think in universe
there was only a few things
then you throw out half of them are
carrying [ __ ] uzis which is an
israeli submachine gun
and that was i think late 60s too
i gotta go back but really you didn't
see him in common usage until the 70s
so it's it's ambiguous and then there
were some hk91s in there
or g3 rifles i guess it might have been
60s
70s i think maybe they're talking about
the 1970s
but the the the uniforms they're wearing
as though it's just od green
and you know by 85 they were using
[ __ ] bdus which are camouflage
well like i said i don't think i don't
think in the universe i don't think it's
supposed to be said in the 80s yes it
can't be
like in the timeline i don't know if
they really put that much thought into
it
right but i don't think that it was
supposed to be i think it was only
supposed to be like a little
a little while you know me my [ __ ]
attention to the military detail
i'm [ __ ] my friend my mind's kind of
spinning when is this supposed to be
taking place
yeah i mean that's but they were they
were cool guns and then
because i really couldn't tell what the
hell was going on in terms of the time
and the military situation i just say
this is comedy
that's how i'm interpreting it or it's
just like a fun fun movie
yeah that's what i mean that's i i don't
take it all that seriously like i said i
don't know if it was like
intentionally a comedy because it does
seem like um
it's it's a very angry movie the first
and the second one though were a lot
more realistic
yeah yeah like with the settings and you
know i mean
you knew what time frame this was
happening in
yeah you know um so i guess i guess
day of the dead is almost kind of like
it's a post-apocalyptic movie
yeah and they they're they're all
carrying relics of the past around so
maybe they were down here 20
years i don't know well it could have
been because the thing about it is that
an
in universe and it's weird because the
the place where they shot like all the
underground scenes
um it was like this uh this big like
mine it was like an old mine in
pennsylvania yeah the
setting is great and um that mine was
actually used
for what they said it was during the
movie where they said that was there was
old hollywood films stored down there
there was all like government records it
was all this kind of stuff
and they didn't nobody really used it
anymore but that's what it was used for
and so george romero basically like
wrote the script around that location
yeah
just because they wanted to use it so
and all the bats and [ __ ] that were
flying around
they're like it was cold down there like
it was all cold and wet and like it was
all [ __ ] up their equipment a lot of
them slept down there because yeah
it was so far like that that was the
great old-school
way of making a movie that's what they
do with escape from new york basically
they had a burned out [ __ ] part i
think it
was a chicago or something that was
burnt for i thought it was st
louis yeah or some somewhere like that
somewhere in the midwest they had a huge
[ __ ] blocks and blocks and blocks of
burned out city and [ __ ] carpenter
goes we're gonna make a movie on here
we're going to make a movie here because
you just
you can't buy a setting like that well
yeah i mean look what they did with like
session nine with that [ __ ] creepy
ass
like abandoned mental hospital yeah it's
like we got to write a movie about this
[ __ ]
yes escape from new york
[ __ ] fantastic class but yeah so the
same thing happened here where it's like
they they basically had that location
and he wanted to write something to do
with that
um although the all the exterior scenes
were actually shot in florida
in fort myers and on santa belle island
um because george romero was living
there at the time
so basically what ended up happening
with this now obviously net of the
living dead huge success
dawn of the dead huge success um both
critically and
you know with audiences so basically
george romero
is kind of like riding high at the time
because a lot of people were like oh you
know he's
he's actually like a cool filmmaker and
he's being successful and everything
so he got i believe it was a three
picture deal i can't remember
um [ __ ] i can't remember the production
company but they gave him a three
picture deal
they said look you can make whatever you
want as long as one of them
is a sequel to dawn of the dead and he
was like okay but i don't really want to
do a sequel
right now so first he made knight riders
uh with tom savini with the you know the
guys on the nights i think ed harris was
in that too like it was terrible the
motorcycle guys he did that that was
terrible yeah he made that movie
and then he made creep show which that's
good was [ __ ] epic yeah
now the stupid thing about that and we
talked about this a little bit i think
on our creep show review but it's like
when creep show came out i mean now it's
like a [ __ ] classic i mean everybody
[ __ ] loves creep show because it's
amazing
but when it came out everyone was kind
of like meh
you know they didn't really which is
amazing to me but whatever
um so george romero was kind of like
well [ __ ] man i'm like making all this
stuff and no one's really
all that into it so then he decides he
finally goes around and make day of the
dead now like i said he had
the location and his first
his first script i think was like two
hours
two and a half hours long something like
that he said he wanted to make quote
unquote the gone with the wind
of zombie movies so he had like this
really
like um kind of massive like idea
that he wanted to do and i'm not sure
exactly what it all entailed
but because knight riders tanked and
because creep show didn't do as well as
they expected it to do
they basically i mean initially day of
the dead was supposed to have like a
seven eight million dollar
budget and the production company was
like yeah we're cutting that in half so
he had to like pare down
the script for like only three and a
half million instead of he thought he
was gonna have like seven or eight
million to make the [ __ ]
so he had to really like kind of take
out a lot of [ __ ] that he wanted so he
basically had to like restructure the
whole thing
but i mean okay so there's like a
documentary
and it's called the world's end i think
it came out in 2013.
um i think it used to be on shutter but
i didn't see it on there anymore but you
can watch it for free on youtube because
i just watched it earlier today
and george romero basically said yeah
you know i did have to like cut down the
script because you know the you know the
budget got cut in half
but he's like the movie that you see is
the movie that i wanted to make it's not
kind of like oh i didn't get to make the
movie i wanted or blah blah blah
although one thing that did happen was
that the production company
were like because he was like well i
want to make it
that was another reason that they cut
the budget in half was because he wanted
to say i
i don't want it to be rated i want to be
unrated so i can do all the gore and
[ __ ] like that that i want
and they were like um yeah okay but
we don't want you to do that so it's
like then you know they they have the
budget too
so that was another reason why but he
was like
look i i want this movie to be like
super over the top gory and [ __ ] like
that and i will say
that is easily easily the best thing
about this movie is the gore
is incredible yeah the [ __ ] effects
look
[ __ ] great there's a lot more to this
movie than gore though
oh yes but i'm saying that's my favorite
part of it for me it was
a couple of the characters really stood
out well first of all i'm gonna say the
setting
is [ __ ] fantastic i didn't appreciate
it
on my first viewings of this you know
now that i'm a little older and it's
been a long time since i've seen it i
look at it now says yeah that [ __ ]
mind setting was [ __ ]
very believable kind of had the feeling
of [ __ ] being trapped in that damn
oh yeah well because they were i mean
because the crew were living down there
there are three
characters that really stand out in
terms of good acting the female
scientist what was her name
oh yeah um sarah dr sarah bowman yeah
that's a that's a really well-acted
character she did a great job on that
[ __ ] dr frankenstein yeah
i love that guy that guy did oh [ __ ]
knocked that performance out of the park
and was seeing that character now
i gotta check the dates but that's gotta
be the prototype
for the herbert west character that um
well what what's his name jeffrey comes
jeffrey combs played because
the cadence of his voice is very similar
and also how he got
mad that is exactly dr herbert west
now see i wonder if one ripped off the
other or if it was just kind of like
they're like okay act like a mad
scientist and that was just the first
thing that came to those two guys minds
i'm not really sure i got a strange
feeling i'm pretty sure that dawn of the
uh that day the dead came out
first when did rihanna but see i thought
they came out the same year
i thought they came out with the same
feeling that jeffrey calms
ripped that character off or like i said
it might have been the other way around
because i didn't
check or like i said if they came out
the same year then it would be really
hard to
maybe they just influenced each other
somehow maybe they knew each other
i'd like to find that out but but i'm
watching that guy do that performance
and i'm like that's herbert west
yeah he seemed a lot like herbert that's
herbert west and [ __ ]
that's the same character played by two
different guys yeah
and then the third character that knocks
it out of the park is a dude that played
[ __ ]
the zombies that's a [ __ ] great
performance everybody loves bob
it's all facial acting he's a theater
actor he did a great job on that
that that was academy award-winning
acting george romero said that too
like on the documentary absolutely
that's how
that should have got it i feel like he
said he should have got a
[ __ ] [ __ ] oscar for that [ __ ] that
is exactly
his performance was perfect because
dude the zombie is the first time you're
kind of like having a relationship with
this zombie through the screen you're
like yeah i understand it
the i [ __ ] the the eye acting
and the facial expression amazing and
the [ __ ] perfect
perfect knocked it out apart best zombie
performance ever
well that's why i mean and you can see
now why bub
is on like so much of the subsequent
merchandising and stuff like that
because people really responded
and what's funny is that bub ends up
being a heroic
[ __ ] figure in the [ __ ] movie yeah
he does he yeah he he exceeded the sum
of his parts
you know what i mean he [ __ ] avenged
the death of his friend who was a living
person
yeah yeah he was very much like a
frankenstein's monster kind of
performance
where he's very like sympathetic or like
king kong or something like that like a
sympathetic monster type you can choose
to be a zombie it just happened to him
yeah it's like he couldn't help it
yeah he can't help it so i really liked
so i really liked and i know that uh
romero went
went in that direction subsequently like
with land of the dead and stuff like
that where
the zombies were starting to like be
like somewhat intelligent and could
actually start to plan
and [ __ ] like that so this was kind of
the the genesis of that and bub was the
first one because that was kind of dr
frankenstein's uh
his name was dr logan really but
everybody everybody was called everybody
calling a frankenstein during the movie
but um that was kind of his even though
he was batshit insane
um he had like the right idea he had
like good intentions he was like look
we have to live on a planet with all
these zombies
and we can't kill them all because we
don't have enough you know ammo we don't
there's not enough of us
so it's like we have to make them docile
we have to like train them
to not eat us you know what i'm saying
there's something tonally about that
character not only did that character
remind me of herbert west he also kind
of reminded me of blair
in the thing yeah yeah yeah i see what
you're saying
yeah he actually was he ended up being
bad [ __ ] crazy
yeah in the end or not really it's just
that i understand why he was doing what
he was doing
yeah it made sense yeah but it didn't
make practical sense
you couldn't you couldn't civilize all
those [ __ ] zombies no but it's like i
i kind of got to the point too where
it's like if they
thought that they were the only people
left on earth which subsequently like in
land of the dead and stuff you find out
that there
actually were other people but these
people think that they are the only
people left it's like they show at the
beginning they go out in the helicopter
they go 100 miles and so
then nobody's there they go to like the
street and it's just like a bunch of
[ __ ] zombies and an alligator
uh you know comes out like in the
streets of fort myers or whatever
and so they think no one's alive but
them so it's kind of like what else are
they gonna do
and they all hate each other they can't
live in this [ __ ] mind like forever
so they at least wanna have some some
hope i guess of like just going
somewhere and not having zombies just
like wanting to eat their faces all the
time
so it's like what else what else could
you do so like i said even though dr
logan
is a crazy person um
he's he has a completely like valid
idea and he has like a valid idea of
like he does horrible things like
spoiler alert he does end up he doesn't
kill
the soldiers like later he doesn't start
but but he does for sure like take their
dead bodies and experiment on them
without telling
anybody um you know what i mean so the
like the the very famous uh effect of
like the guy
who's just laying there on the table
like his whole head is gone and it's
just like his little brain sticking up
yeah fun fact tom savini and his crew
called that
gag the moose [ __ ]
just because of like what it looked like
like how do you know what a moose [ __ ]
looks like
i'm just not even gonna ask but that's
what they call the movie
the movie has aged pretty well i liked
it better now than i did back when i
did i did too and a lot of people say
that actually it's
over over the top over time it's kind of
[ __ ] aged in a certain way like a
fine wine
there are only really two things that i
would have changed it had been easy
tweaks and i think the movie would have
[ __ ]
ended up benefiting from it but you know
it's the director's going to make this
call
the first thing i would have done is i
would have toned down the soldiers and
changed their tweak their dialogue just
a little bit
yeah they're very shouty so they weren't
quite over the top
all right i think they would have been
better played a little more straight
and a little more menacing i think
sometimes
less is more when it comes to medicine
yeah i
would have left him more of a [ __ ] a
[ __ ]
downtone possible threat
instead of something maybe scarier scary
because instead of just like somebody
like
just cackling and yeah too much cackling
and too much over the top
to me kind of was detrimental they
didn't feel threatening they just felt
like idiots
um which i think took away that took
took away their
the power which and that wasn't even
like so much i mean rhodes was slightly
over the top but it wasn't even so much
him that bothered me it was
it was like the fat guy like those other
like because they were just like going
around
yeah you know just like all the time no
i think rhodes did pretty good job i
would have yeah a little less
shouty but like i said you know that's
the director's call i don't really agree
with that one
the second thing that would have been a
super easy tweak i think that what the
movie would have benefited from
is to get rid of the fake accents you
don't need to have a jamaican
accent on the guy you don't need an
irish accent i mean
you're not those accents didn't work
maybe they did back in those days but we
live in a globalized society everybody
knows what the accidents
really sound like now and if you can't
[ __ ] do it
perfectly don't do it it'd have been
better if they were just
american guys if they just talked the
way they would normally yeah and and i
think those characters
would have been remembered a little more
the the [ __ ] the black guy
should have basically been played
straight a kind of character that you
know
um oh [ __ ] um
who's the dude i'm thinking of did play
played uh across kurt russell in a thing
um
did all the voiceovers for all the
[ __ ] yeah what's his name um
and then uh the other guy he was kind of
reminded me
of the character from
um alien one the uh
[Music]
the uh the guy who [ __ ] works down in
with the mechanics
yeah remember the guy just said right
yeah yeah you should just bend that guy
right i forgot what his name was in the
character
yeah i can't i'm not really sure why
exactly
keith david yeah a helicopter pilot
basically should have been a character
kind of like keith david's
character in in the thing you know what
i mean which is just straight
african-american guy
because he was doing heroic [ __ ] in the
movie remember that he saved the
guns on the soldiers and [ __ ] so i think
he would have come across
as a stronger character just in his own
accent yeah because he was
talking in the documentary too and he
just he's just sort of an american guy
so he doesn't um
and it's really weird because romero
like asked him like hey can you do a
west indian accent and he did it and
he's like okay do that so it's like
so like i said i don't think there was
any there wasn't really any script
reason for him to have to be yeah like
west india you don't have like
to be jamaican i just think it was some
extra [ __ ] maybe it would have played
well back in the 80s but it just didn't
age as well
as it would today he'd have been better
if it was just a straight american dude
maybe that's the thing i i kind of feel
like maybe in the mid 80s there was kind
of a thing where it's like they liked
having like jamaican dudes in their
movies
megan dude so they wanted more exotic
kind of characters in the movies
yeah maybe that's what it was everybody
had to be some kind of foreigner because
you know what i mean
there weren't there weren't many
foreigners around i guess at the time
maybe his immigration thing i don't know
well and i don't know if it was so much
like well if if these are the only
people left on earth it's like it would
be weird if they were all americans
maybe it's like so maybe that's what he
was thinking
i'm not really sure they're in a missile
silo that's true
okay they're so they're the there's
evidently the revenant remnants of the
military in a science
[ __ ] thing which is that's another
strange thing although certain things do
happen in emergency situations
the army they had army soldiers inside
the missile silos the army doesn't have
any missile silos that's all air force
so to be sometimes people are
get assigned to certain areas in
emergency but just
er to be accurate you know what i mean
chances are it would have been air force
security guys
yeah not army guys but like i said i
kind of feel like i mean i think even
uh the character of sarah she has like a
throwaway line earlier she's like this
operation was put together like in a
couple of days so it was obviously like
the zombie apocalypse was taken over
and like some of the like remnants of
the authorities were like oh [ __ ] maybe
we should like get a scientific team
together and get a couple guys to
protect them and see what we can do
and maybe that's like the only people
that were left so they didn't really
together real quick
yeah because so she does say that like
at one point so it's just like kind of
like all these
this is very ramshackle operation and
they don't even know
if anybody is left out there like to
give them commands or like tell them
what to do so they're just kind of like
stuck down there
yeah exp you know see experimenting and
cutting up all these zombies and all
this other kind of [ __ ] and just going
batshit
crazy down in this [ __ ] mine i think
air force looked cooler though
because the air force never gets enough
screen time they got good air force
security guys
they had a bet and in in that era they
had a badass uniform [ __ ] you know
they've been od green and i think they
had little blue berets and [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah i think that was little ascot
things that looked it would look pretty
cool that one looks cool maybe they
couldn't get their hands on any of those
outfits
yeah maybe because i mean you got to
think too these are like low-budget
movies so they're just kind of like it's
kind of like a catches catch can type of
movie-making thing it's like hey can we
get this that the other no we can't get
that we'll just have to use this
you know what i'm saying they're just
gonna use whatever but like i said i
think
now interestingly george romero uh cited
this as his favorite
of his zombie movies he really really
liked this one um and tom savini i think
has
long said that this is probably like his
best work and i
i don't know i might have to agree with
him on this one because some of the
[ __ ] gags in this
like i said the the [ __ ] the moose
[ __ ] guy like with just the brain left
and the and the body
like all the [ __ ] uh you know people
going over sideways and all their guts
falling out
like [ __ ] roads getting torn in half
and like all the guts and
him going choke on it you know what i
mean that's so [ __ ] great like the
one guy getting his head torn off
one guy getting his eye popped out the
zombie getting this [ __ ]
top of his head cut off with a shovel
it's just like oh and the miguel getting
his [ __ ] arm chopped off and then
[ __ ]
cauterized it's like just the gore in
this is just
it's so so good i mean all of it is like
really
realistic like i think it's like
honestly
dawn of the dead the gore was good in
that too but
i like that they went with like a more
realistic looking zombie
uh appliances and stuff because i feel
like dawn of the dead a lot of the
zombies in that just kind of had like
green makeup on their faces and it
didn't look
quite as cool and this one there's still
a few green zombies like lurking around
the background but what they did
basically was
i mean tom savini has said that you know
a few months before they started
shooting
it's like basically i had me and my
whole crew and we were just
down in my basement making thousands of
zombie appliances for all the extras and
stuff like that like masks and like
pieces of face that could be like put on
and off like really quick
so the fact that they really went the
extra mile
to do the [ __ ] effects like as
realistic as they were i mean they
really really hold up
yeah i mean and i have still looked
looks really good too i understand i saw
the gags i know how they did it
yeah me too but i didn't know how they
did it at the time when i first saw it
when i was a kid
i see it now and i go oh that's what you
did i see what you did but you have to
look
you have to look closely you have to
have a knowledge of magic and [ __ ]
special effects
but back in the day when i saw this it
was [ __ ]
mind-blowing especially when they
[ __ ] took that head off that body and
the head still looked alive
and the and the eyes were still yeah and
i didn't see the cut
yeah i bought i bought the whole shot
can i tell you my favorite part of that
scene where that dude gets his head torn
off yeah
is that when his head is turned off and
he's screaming and then like the
what the scream gets higher and higher
pitched until it like comes out and i'm
like oh that was a nice touch i really
like that they [ __ ] thought of that
it's just like that makes me so happy
that they like put
that much thought into like these gags
well yeah like i said i think that
i might have i can't remember the name
of that old tom savini documentary that
came out
[ __ ] man it must have came out in 86 87
something like that because i think that
day of the dead was the most recent film
that he had worked on when that
documentary came out
i think i saw the documentary about him
before i saw this movie so like when i
saw the movie i already knew like how
all they did all the gags and everything
like that but i don't
i don't think that like takes away from
it at all and like i said i
i really think this is kind of like the
pinnacle of like the practical effects
that you've done there i mean they are
disgusting
and the and the um the very famous story
about this one particularly that last
scene where
rhodes gets torn in half by the zombies
um they used all real
pig guts they got like these big five
gallon drums of them
and they said and we reused them like
for people we'd put them in like the
[ __ ] chest cavities and all this
other kind of [ __ ]
it's like you'd do the scene you'd scoop
them back into the [ __ ] bucket and
you put the bucket
in the refrigerator so he's like so
basically
we did some of the gags we put the
buckets in the refrigerator
and then we went down to florida because
we were shooting some exteriors down
there and then we were going to come
back and like shoot
rhodes's death scene when they came back
it had been like a couple of weeks or
something like that and someone had
unplugged the refrigerator
that they were keeping all the pig guts
in and they said you could smell it from
like a couple blocks
away and if you see like the behind the
scenes [ __ ] where they were shooting
that scene
with rose getting torn in half it's like
you can see all the zombies like doing
this they said
rhodes the gut the actor that played him
i was just watching the documentary but
he said i can still smell it to this day
it was like the smell was just like
undescribable
it's just like these rotten [ __ ] because
he was right there and he didn't have
they're like we couldn't put anything
like up his nose or anything like that
because you could see it like on the
camera
so it's like he basically just had to
like he's like some of the zombies had
like [ __ ]
you know vaporub or like english leather
or something like that like underneath
their [ __ ] so it would like kind of
mitigate it a little bit but he didn't
have anything
and he's like you can see it's like he
really just looked like he wanted to
hurl like after they said cut it was
like so [ __ ] sad
but i was like see that's like [ __ ]
commitment to realism
right there that we love in our [ __ ]
zombie movies that's why i love tom
savanni it makes you want to see
uh dawn of the dead now yeah i was a
it's weird that like i said that we
decided to do this one first but
didn't somebody send us dawn of the dead
on dvd or was it david dead that
somebody sent us
i don't did somebody say somebody sent
us this
i'm not really sure well i had to go we
have like such a huge pile
yeah and now the thing about this so
like i said this is free
on 2b at the moment um they did a remake
of this
i think in 2008 that i think went direct
to
video i have not seen it um they also
did
day of the dead bloodline that came out
in 2018
now that might also be on tubey or it
might be on shutter i can't remember
i heard that wasn't too bad um i might
check it out like the remake that they
made in 2008 they said
pretty much other than it being set like
in an underground bunker and like some
of the
characters names being the same it's
like pretty much a completely different
movie i haven't seen them i got to see
some of these newer ones
um now i will say the remake of dawn of
the dead which they did in 2004 was
actually pretty [ __ ] good
i don't remember that one i didn't think
it was gonna be good but
it's not that much like the original but
it's just a really good like zombie
movie in its own right have i seen that
one
i doubt it i saw it in the theater and
then like i saw it subsequently again
like on cable
i gotta i gotta check them out again
some of the newer ones but like i said i
didn't even realize there was a remake
of dawn
of day of the dead from 2008 until like
i was looking at the wikipedia page i
knew about bloodline because i'd seen it
like when i was scrolling through a
movie somewhere else and i was like dude
what i was like i didn't
i can't keep them all straight because
there's also spin-offs yeah they're
spin-offs and like i said and george
romero kept making
like he made one called land of the dead
um he made
diary of the dead which was like a found
footage yeah which
i didn't love it was okay he was trapped
on the roof
are trapped in the store and they're the
show and he's showing each other
messages they're looking [ __ ] man
now i can't even remember yeah there's
some there's so many [ __ ]
land of the dead was the one with dennis
hopper
in it yeah they had the big [ __ ] bus
with the big bit bus and the big
building john leguizamo was in it
yeah i liked that one actually i've seen
that one in forever yeah i liked that
one
i think the sadly though i think a lot
and please
uh correct me if i'm wrong but i thought
most of the gore in that was
cgi which was kind of a bummer like
especially because
the practical effects in this one were
so [ __ ] good
and i just it was another era and the
scope of these old movies was a lot
smaller
you're only like in a couple locations
and
you know what i mean you didn't have to
pack
so much stuff into a movie like you do
now now everything's cg they're going to
show you all these different [ __ ]
locations
something has to be happening every five
seconds yeah because they can green
screen you anywhere
you don't have to actually be there yeah
it's just funny
because sometimes that's works when it's
done real well other times now you get
the feeling of
it doesn't feel real yeah like i said
it's like everyone's if
they feel like it's really happening in
a location and it feels like you're
actually seeing something that actually
exists
yeah and the scope of the story is a lot
smaller which
which makes them a little more intimate
in a certain way
well i think maybe that's why i find it
like easier to relate to a lot of these
like older zombies because at least
there's like a couple of characters and
only a few characters
and you know i don't really think you
necessarily need to i think that's what
happened with the movie
version of um what the [ __ ] was it world
war z or whatever that's i think that's
why i didn't like that one yeah
is because they tried too hard to like
show you the global scope
of the zombie apocalypse but i think you
know trying to do that
you know that's fine but this is more if
you don't have
like a connection like to a small group
of people or care that you care if they
die or anything then
all of that is not going to matter to
you because people's brains just can't
take all that in less is more in a
zombie movie we saw that one
remember that korean zombie movie we
just saw where the guy was trapped in
the damn apartment
yeah and the girl was in the apartment
across the way yeah hashtag alive
yeah see that's how you do it that was a
good movie yeah because you it was like
two characters and you gave a [ __ ] about
that you're
like you didn't want them to get eaten
yeah yeah it's like yeah i get that
everybody's zombies i get that you don't
gotta like
show like look the zombies like taking
over the whole city i get that
you don't have to you don't got to show
me yeah no small-scale i believe a
small-scale personal story of just a
couple people
that's all you need so i like i mean day
of the dead they did have the one cool
scene near the beginning
where you know it's like the beginning
sequence where they go out in the
helicopter
and they go to the street like i said
they shot in fort myers florida um
and there's just like nobody around it's
just garbage and then they start yelling
for people and then like all the zombies
start coming out
so i think that was like the first time
you got to see like
an abandoned city like in george
romero's
zombie movies and that was cool but
that's all you need
i mean that's all you need you just show
one thing it's like look everybody's
dead
everybody's zombies let's get back into
like the character drama and the gore
and watch
dr frankenstein cutting up zombie bodies
and talking to bub and getting him to
like
fire guns and listen to a walkman yeah
you know
so you know but yeah so day of the dead
if you haven't seen it and you're
if you really like gore you'll be into
it because i really really like the
the [ __ ] on this but the character drama
is really good too like i said
could have done with a little toning
down not so much roads but like his
sidekicks yeah well there's only two
changes
there's only two changes i would have
made and that was the accents and the
[ __ ] tone of the [ __ ]
beta yeah the supporting soldiers but
man you know that's kind of modern
okay that's kind of minor yeah that
doesn't make a big difference
and uh the movie's enjoyable to watch
it's it's it's like like it's like an
enjoyable [ __ ] show
basically i mean all of romero's movies
are enjoyable i think that's kind of why
people still remember him as like king
of the zombie movies nowadays
it's not a post-apocalyptic feel to it
yeah it feels like the other ones and
you're like going yeah okay and it's
real like claustrophobic because they're
all just like all these people just like
sniping at each other in this little
underground kind of [ __ ]
crazy implausible [ __ ] happens but you
don't care you're like yeah okay
it's just you know well a zombie
apocalypse is not all that plausible so
it's like you know you got to suspend
your disbelief when you're into like
horror it's just
fun yeah it's a fun movie that's what
it's supposed to be yeah exactly
all right so that'll do it for our uh
discussion of
george ramirez day of the dead and uh
we'll see you on the next one
bye